[Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Jetzt zur Erdbeerzeit möchte ich ein super Rezept mit euch teilen,
nämlich Hi-Hat Muffins.
Das ist ein Muffin, der im Inneren eine Erdbeere hat
und dann wie so ein Schaumkuss diese Marshmallow-Masse on top
plus Kuvertüre überzogen.
Ich muss mich ein bisschen entschuldigen.
Wir haben heute eine Baustelle draußen.
Die Stadt Waghäusel hat es sich zur Aufgabe gemacht,
die Gehsteige aufzureißen und wir haben heute Tonprobleme,
aber ich hoffe, es klappt. Ich hoffe, ihr verzeiht mir.
Wir kriegen das hin.
Ansonsten machen wir heute einen Stummfilm, Josh.
Dann machen wir das mit Gestik und Mimik.
[Geräusche vom Filmapparat]
Das versteht man doch.
Und ich – mag – Yam Yam. [Lacht]
Ich zeige euch einmal die Zutaten.
Ich mache jetzt einmal einen Basic-Teig und danach 2 Versionen,
nämlich helle und dunkle Muffins,
und später auch zwei Versionen im Überzug.
Ich glaube, es wird sehr lecker
und ich denke, die Kinder und das Team werden es lieben
- ich natürlich auch, Josh auch, Sarah auch, und alle!
Für den Teig verwende ich 120 g Zucker, 1 Prise Salz, 200 g Mehl,
3/4 TL Backpulver und 1/4 TL Natron, 50 g gemahlene Mandeln,
2 Eier, 200 g Buttermilch, 150 g Sonnenblumenöl.
Für die dunklen Schoko-Muffins nehme ich dann noch etwas Kakao,
Kakao-Nips und diese Schoko-Crisps in Zartbitter, Tonka Wonka
und für die helle Version die weißen Schoko-Crisps und Vanilleextrakt.
Diese Schoko-Crisps kennt ihr mittlerweile. Die benutze ich gern.
Das ist ein kleiner Keks, der mit Schokolade überzogen ist.
Die könnt ihr mit backen, als Deko verwenden,
als bunte Streusel benutzen.
Ich finde es auch schön, wenn man eine Deko hat, die auch schmeckt.
Deswegen mag ich Schokoladendekorationen echt gern.
Jetzt könnt ihr hier die trockenen Zutaten verrühren,
also erst einmal den Zucker, Salz, Mehl, Backpulver und Natron
und die Mandeln - die dürft ihr auch gern weglassen.
[Musik]
Dann kurz verrühren.
Jetzt gebt ihr noch die flüssigen Zutaten dazu,
also Eier, Buttermilch
- wenn ihr keine Buttermilch habt, könnt ihr auch Milch benutzen
und einen Spritzer Zitronensaft dazu geben,
denn das Natron braucht ein bisschen Säure.
Jetzt verrührt ihr die Zutaten kurz.
Dafür braucht man auch kein Handgerät.
[Musik]
Dann halbiere ich jetzt den Teig.
Das kann ich ganz gut machen, weil ich ihn im Messbecher drin habe.
Das sind jetzt bei mir 700 ml.
[Musik]
Zur Hälfte gebe ich jetzt die Schokozutaten dazu.
Kakao-Nips sind ja einfach die gebrochene Kakaobohne,
also einfach die ursprünglichste Art der Schokolade.
Da passt Tonka Wonka dazu oder auch etwas Abrieb der Tonkabohne.
Die Zutaten kurz einrühren.
[Musik]
Und dann noch die helle Version mit Vanilleextrakt.
Jetzt habe ich beide Teige fertig.
Ihr seht, das geht auch ganz schnell.
Jetzt nehme ich hier einen Eisportionierer
- das ist der größte, den ich habe -,
habe hier eine Muffin-Form mit Papierförmchen ausgelegt
und kann jetzt die Muffins befüllen,
wie gesagt, dann habe ich jetzt 6 helle und 6 dunkle.
Den Ofen habe ich auch schon vorgeheizt auf 200°C Ober-/Unterhitze.
Dann werden die direkt im Ofen gebacken, bis sie gar sind.
[Musik]
Die Muffins kühlen gerade noch aus.
Jetzt kann ich schon einmal das Hi-Hat Topping machen.
Das ist also eine Marshmallow-Masse aus Eiweiß.
Also wenn ihr auch einmal Eiweiß übrighabt,
könnt ihr es hier wirklich super verwerten.
Dafür nehme ich 4 Eiweiß, 1 Prise Salz, 200 g Zucker,
1/2 TL Weinstein und 1 TL Vanilleextrakt.
Weinstein gibt in Deutschland so eigentlich gar nicht zu kaufen,
aber ihr könnt einfach Weinsteinpulver nehmen.
Das bewirkt das Gleiche, nämlich,
dass diese Eiweißmasse später schön stabil bleibt
- sozusagen ein Stabilisator.
Weinsteinbackpulver finde ich sowieso immer besser
als herkömmliches Backpulver.
Jetzt ist nur wichtig, dass praktisch die Zutaten verrührt
und erhitzt werden, damit das Eiweiß nicht mehr roh ist
und damit es die Standfestigkeit bekommt.
Ich mache das jetzt ganz klassisch auf dem Herd über einem Wasserbad,
aber wenn ihr habt,
könnt ihr auch ganz gern die Kenwood Cooking Chef nehmen,
das Ganze mit dem Schneebesen verrühren, 70°C, 10 Minuten.
Dann spart man sich auch das Rühren.
Ich gebe jetzt alle Zutaten hier hinein. Das ist wirklich ganz einfach.
Ein bisschen Vanille für den Geschmack.
Die Eiweißmasse rührt ihr dann 10 Minuten auf dem Herd
über dem warmen Wasserbad. Nur ein bisschen aufpassen:
Es darf nicht zu arg kochen, eher so mittelhohe Hitze,
damit es einfach nur schön warm und auf 70°C erhitzt wird.
Dann nehmt ihr es runter und könnt es noch einmal
etwa 5 Minuten weiterrühren, damit es wieder etwas abkühlt.
Die Marshmallow-Masse ist jetzt fertig.
Die fülle ich jetzt direkt in einen Spritzbeutel
mit einer großen Lochtülle ein.
Was mache ich denn da? [Lacht]
Der Ton heute! Der Ton verwirrt mich heute,
denn mir hängt so eine Angel über dem Kopf.
Hatte ich jetzt so auch noch nicht.
JOSH: Ja, dann müssen wir improvisieren, wenn der Funk ausfällt.
SALLY: Funk fällt aus, aber wir kriegen es trotzdem hin.
Ich bin nur ein bisschen bewegungseingeschränkt.
Ich nehme jetzt hier meinen Muffin.
Normalerweise kann man bei Hi-Hat Muffins einfach die Masse nehmen
und hier darauf spritzen.
Ich will aber noch die Erdbeere in die Mitte.
Deswegen schneide ich mir jetzt hier eine gerade Fläche,
höhle sie auch ein bisschen aus,
damit die Erdbeere da Platz nehmen kann,
setze die Erdbeere hinein.
Damit sie gleich beim Eintauchen in die Kuvertüre
nicht herausflutscht, befestige ich sie mit einem Zahnstocher.
Den nehme ich später aber heraus, bevor ich die Cupcakes serviere,
damit sich keiner daran verletzt. Aber so hält die Erdbeere.
Dann kommt jetzt die Masse drumherum.
Am besten haltet ihr den Spritzbeutel senkrecht,
umrandet erst einmal die Erdbeere
und zieht dann die Marshmallow-Masse wie einen Hut nach oben.
[Musik]
So sehen sie bisher aus. Die werden auch direkt fest,
also diese Masse steht dann echt gut.
Jetzt nehmt ihr euch am besten Kuvertüre,
entweder Zartbitter, Weiß, Vollmilch, Ruby, Karamell
- was euch am besten schmeckt.
Ich mache die dunklen mit Ruby-Kuvertüre,
also die rosa Schokoladensorte,
und die hellen mit dunkler Schokolade.
Die solltet ihr temperieren,
d. h. 2/3 davon erwärmt ihr über dem warmen Wasserbad,
nehmt es dann herunter, rührt das restliche 1/3 ein,
ein bisschen Kokosfett
und dann hat es die perfekte Weiterverarbeitungstemperatur,
damit die Kuvertüre keinen grauen Schleier bekommt
und eben auch schön fest wird und glänzt.
Die Ruby habe ich schon temperiert.
Die dunkle steht noch auf dem Herd.
Jetzt hoffe ich einfach nur,
dass der Marshmallow-Hut mit der Erdbeere hält.
Also ohne Erdbeere hält er auf jeden Fall;
mit Erdbeere ist es ein bisschen Glückssache.
[Musik]
Ah! [Lacht] Das war wirklich zu tief!
Oh nein! Heijajai.
Ihr solltet auf jeden Fall darauf achten,
dass die Umrandung ein bisschen mehr auf dem Muffin liegt,
denn dann klebt der Hut.
[Musik]
Wie so eine Antenne.
Wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr noch gefriergetrocknete Erdbeeren nehmen
und diese darüber bröseln.
[Musik]
Am besten stellt ihr die Muffins mit dem Schaumkusstopping
in den Kühlschrank oder kurz in den Gefrierschrank,
damit sie schön kalt werden
und die Kuvertüre nach dem Eintauchen direkt fest wird.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr einmal einiges an Kuvertüre übrighabt
und sie aber auch nicht direkt weiterverarbeiten wollt,
könnt ihr sie auch ganz praktisch in Eiswürfelformen füllen,
festwerden lassen und könnt sie so einzeln portionieren
und verpacken und dann das nächste Mal weiterverwenden.
Die Hi-Hat Muffins sind jetzt fertig und auch ausgehärtet.
Heute darf Josh probieren. [Jubel]
JOSH: Hallo!
SALLY: Josh!
JOSH: Ja?
SALLY: Hast du so etwas schon einmal gesehen?
JOSH: Nein! Ich war voll überrascht, als du mir das gezeigt hast.
SALLY: Oh, ich muss den Zahnstocher...
JOSH: Ich bin sehr gespannt. Oh Gott, ja!
SALLY: Oh Gott, die Zahnstocher müssen raus!
Die waren ja nur zur Befestigung.
Stell dir vor, man beißt da rein und dann...
JOSH: Das ist echt gefährlich. Da muss man schon aufpassen.
SALLY: Also wirklich darauf achten: Alle Zahnstocher wieder entfernen!
Ich lege den einmal da hin.
Ich glaube... Also mein Gefühl sagt mir...
- ich habe ja schon einmal Hi-Hat Muffins gebacken,
so ganz normale Standard,
aber mit Erdbeeren sind schon noch einmal Hi-Hat Deluxe.
Ich glaube, wenn man Schaumküsse mag, dann mag man sie.
JOSH: Ja, Schaumküsse finde ich eigentlich ganz lecker.
Sind Hi-Hat Muffins nicht zwangsläufig
mit so einer Füllung im Topping?
SALLY: Nein, man kann sie auch ohne die Erdbeere zubereiten.
JOSH: Aber das wäre vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel, oder?
SALLY: Guck mal!
Oh, wie schön!
JOSH: Nicht schlecht! Nicht schlecht!
SALLY: Weil ich glaube einfach auch, dass die Erdbeere das Ganze
geschmacklich durch die Säure abrundet. [Josh stimmt zu]
Ich weiß nicht... Welchen willst du probieren, oder beide?
Ach komm, probiere beide!
JOSH: Tendenziell bin eher der Zartbitterschokolade-Fan.
SALLY: Ich auch, aber ich muss sagen,
der Schoko-Muffin schmeckt auch sehr gut mit Tonka.
Ruby ist auch lecker.
Ich glaube, du kommst nicht drumherum.
JOSH: Nein, das ist okay! Kann ich mit leben. [Lacht]
Aber wie essen wir sie? Weil die sind ja so...
[Beide lachen]
SALLY: Also ich würde sagen: Papier weg.
JOSH: Auf einen Bissen.
SALLY: Schälen und dann reinbeißen.
Naja, nimmst du so quer.
[Beide lachen]
Man nimmt es so quer und dann beißt man so rein.
JOSH: Ah!
SALLY: Das habe ich auf der Cupcake-Schule gelernt.
Guck, so!
JOSH: Ja, da war ich krank.
SALLY: Man dreht sich von der Kamera weg.
JOSH: Da war ich krank an dem Tag.
Boah! Ich glaube, dass muss sogar ich machen.
[Sally lacht]
Ich verkrümle dann ja auch alles auf den Boden.
Oh, vergiss es! Ich verliere alles.
Mmh! Aber voll lecker. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Mit der Erdbeere!
JOSH: So, und weiter!
SALLY: Ich habe ein Ganzes zerstört.
Der Boden ist schon so gut, der Muffin.
JOSH: Mega saftig. [Sally stimmt zu]
Also ein bisschen schwierig zu essen. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Nichts für das erste Date.
Ach egal!
JOSH: Hat man was zu lachen. [Sally lacht]
Das ist doch auch nicht schlecht.
SALLY: Ich dachte immer, bei Muffinsbacken kann man nichts falsch machen,
bis ich einmal auf einer Halloween-Party war und es gab Muffins
und die waren einfach trocken und wie Stein. Die waren echt steinhart.
Deswegen benutzt wirklich das Grundrezept von mir
und nehmt kein Handrührgerät,
sondern wirklich nur einen Löffel oder einen Schneebesen,
rührt alle Zutaten nur kurz durch.
Dann werden sie echt schön locker und saftig.
Die Buttermilch trägt ihren Beitrag dazu...
Ein falscher Satz.
JOSH: Sie trägt ihren Beitrag dazu? Sie trägt dazu bei!
Sie leistet ihren Beitrag und trägt dann dazu bei.
SALLY: [Lacht] Sie leistet ihren Beitrag – Ach Gott!
Ja, gut!
Wie wir einfach nicht reden können vor lauter Essen.
BEIDE: Mmh!
SALLY: Was ist dein Favorit?
[Beide lachen]
JOSH: Du hast beide?
SALLY: Ich habe einen nur probiert, diesen hier.
Den habe ich noch nicht probiert.
JOSH: Ah, wir haben getauscht probiert.
SALLY: Ja. Warte, ich probiere noch so.
JOSH: Oh ja, das ist gut. Weißt du was?
SALLY: Oh, der Schoko-Muffin...
JOSH: Der ist mega lecker, gell? [Sally stimmt zu]
Jetzt hole ich noch den hellen.
Oh Gott! Okay, ich mache danach sauber.
SALLY: Wir machen sauber.
Aber echt gut.
JOSH: Der helle ist auch sehr lecker.
SALLY: Ich kann mich nicht entscheiden. Ich finde beide Muffins sehr gut,
hell und dunkel. [Josh stimmt zu]
Deswegen macht ruhig beide Varianten, hell und dunkel.
Was ich vor allem sehr gut finde:
Diese Schoko-Crips-Pearls, diese Kekse.
Die Schokolade schmilzt zwar, aber das hinterlässt so einen richtig
schönen Geschmack und vor allem diesen Crunch.
JOSH: Voll! Man merkt so ein bisschen, dass, wenn man draufbeißt,
es dann so ein bisschen kracht, hat so ein bisschen Biss.
Ich finde auch die gefriergetrockneten Erdbeeren
und die Schokosplitter machen mega viel aus! [Sally stimmt zu]
Die sind einfach so dieses...
SALLY: Das stimmt.
JOSH: Bisschen, was es dann ergänzt.
SALLY: Also schon ein cooles Rezept, oder?
JOSH: Voll! Ein bisschen ein Schlachtfeld, aber echt lecker.
SALLY: Egal, macht nichts!
JOSH: Superlecker!
SALLY: Also probiert es gern aus. Das Rezept findet ihr in meiner App
oder auf meinem Blog.
Statt Erdbeeren... Was könnte man noch nehmen?
JOSH: Eine Birne? [Lacht]
SALLY: Kiwi?
JOSH: Eine Kiwi? Ja, Kiwi.
SALLY: Jetzt hast du eine Kiwi.
JOSH: Ah ja, da eine Kiwi rein, so ein bisschen schräg anschneiden.
SALLY: Die Erdbeere hat diese perfekte Form dafür,
aber man kann wirklich alles nehmen.
Irgendetwas, was so ein bisschen Säure hat, finde ich.
JOSH: Lasst euch was einfallen!
SALLY: Lasst euch was einfallen; werdet kreativ!
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss!
JOSH: Tschüss!
Ich nehme das mal so mit.
SALLY: Ich kann nicht mehr.
JOSH: Macht’s doch leer! So. Tschüss!
SALLY: Ich nehme das für die Fotos mit.
[Musik]